I'm not a philosopher so I'm going to
dodge the many complicated ethical
questions about cryonics about freezing
someone's body after they die in the
hope that future science will not just
unfreeze them but also cure them of
whatever ended their life the
philosophical side of this is way
outside what I'm qualified to talk about
and honestly my opinion would not be
helpful I will say that I think death is
a bad thing and that Humanity should be
trying to defeat it the same way we've
defeated smallpox but that is a
controversial opinion the questions I do
have for the folks that run this actual
cryonics facility are practical and
legal as ever this is not an advert the
team here have no editorial control I
just got invited to see a place where
the dead are being stored in the hope of
Resurrection currently there's still
very few patients stored here it's more
than zero but you can count it on a very
few hands the exact number we only
release once we have a few more do not
have any potential privacy problems but
it's very few so far the company's
official website describes the bodies in
there as patients but what's being
stored are legally and medically corpses
not people the people have been declared
legally dead and their assets have
passed to their Descendants the cryo
process cannot start until the person is
declared dead because otherwise it's
murder so if someone who signed up is
close to death the company will dispatch
a very non-standard ambulance there
needs to be the least possible delay
between the heart stops and the cooldown
procedure being started and of course
only if the patient has given informed
content before dying and then we start
practically three procedures at the same
time one is we start cooling down as
quick as possible there's a saying in
medicine that says the only debt if
you're warm in debt
the metabolic rate of the cell goes down
and the cell dies slower we also start
very aggressive what is similar to CPR
chest compressions giving oxygen and so
on to give some amount of metabolic
support then before you cross zero
degrees Celsius you want to replace all
the blood and the rest of the water
against a medical grade antifreeze it's
very important to say we don't freeze
anything though of course the headline
always says this organization is
freezing people and so on in more
technical terms we vitrify them which is
like a glass like amorphous state
which allows tissue to be stored without
any further damage in a state where
potentially future technology might be
able to well resuscitate the cryo
process causes massive probably
unrecoverable damage to the body there
is no technology now or even vaguely on
the horizon that could reverse that
damage but whatever is left patient
corpse assembly of Frozen stuff gets
stacked up in stainless steel containers
here submerged in liquid nitrogen until
well until it's possible to recover them
which could very well be never so
obvious question how does a dead person
pay for a service that if all goes to
plan will continue indefinitely while
someone is alive there's a small
membership fee with us and then at the
time of death it's around 200 000 Euros
but this is a one-time fee the largest
part is given to a non-profit
organization
they invest that money with around one
to two percent above inflation in return
expectation sufficient than to maintain
crowd preservation and you have that
money that you put aside inflation
adjusted in the future before well
whatever medical procedure might be
necessary to pay for reintegration for
retraining you know to get used to the
future again one of the goals of our
organization is to over time not only
make the choir preservation procedures
better but also make it significantly
more affordable
somewhere in the you know mid five
figure range maybe should be possible
over time a reminder that's the CEO of
the company his view is going to be
biased but one of the reasons I was
comfortable filming here is that he was
very candid about the chances of this
working we would never state that
there's any X percent that this works
cryopreservation is not a medical
procedure it's a research procedure no
one in the world can say if and when
cryo preservation might work long-term
storage is always done with foundations
we have bylaws and statutes that make
the foundation from day to day
perspective very slow very you know
sluggish and there's a lot of inertia to
change stuff all of that is there to
maximize for longevity I would like to
live on as long as I can as long as I
want to I don't only want that for me
but I think that should be everybody's
right ideally I would never like to be
crime preserved I would like to do
whatever treatment there will be when
I'm 95 and whatever you know medication
I need to take when I'm 60 to then make
that happen
should I die at 60 of a heart attack or
something like that then I'd much rather
be crier preserved than I'm being
cremated or buried it might turn out it
never works but the alternative has as
close to zero a chance as you can
ever have
this right now is an option for a tiny
minority of rich people and it probably
won't work but I do think that Humanity
should be trying to defeat death so I
find it difficult to argue against
someone who take this option
when I know what the alternative is